[موسيقى]
نرحب بكل المشاهدين بكل ضيوف برنامج اسبوع
في العالم وهم زملاء واصدقائه يمكن ان
تتفاعلوا مع ما يقولون على صفحتنا على
فيسبوك او على صفحه البرنامج على تويتر
سنبدا بالطبع بمونديال قطر نقترب من نهايه
المونديال والمنتخب المغربي هو العربي
والافريقي الوحيد الذي يظل في السباق
والمنتخب
البرازيلي
انسحب امام المنتخب
الازمه السياسيه ولا تتطرق الى العلاقات
العربيه الصينيه من خلال زياده
الصابري سعيد بان يكون معنا من القاهره
احمد جمعه وهو كاتب وصحفي وسعيد بان يكون
معنا من لندن خالد عيسى وهو كاتب وصفي هذا
مع ضيفه لندن اللي فاجات كهذه النتيجه
المنتخب البرازيلي
اهلا بك
الكرام وبكل مشاهدي
كم مفاجات وهذه ربما تكون احدى المفاجات
لكن حسب التكتيك والفنيات التي تتقدمتها
بعض الفرق من كان من المتوقع ان تخرج
البرازيل او اي فريق اخر ولكن بكل اسف
شريحه واسع من المشاهدين في العالم اليوم
ربما سيصابه بنوع من الاحباط غدر الماء
لان البرازيل لديها قاعده جماهيريه كبيره
بالتاكيد انا ههه وبالتاكيد انا ايضا يعني
تفاجات في هذه النتيجه طيب
عفوا لم اسمع
[ضحك]
لها الحظ الاوفر في الحصول على هذه
البطوله لانها تقدم اداء استثنائيا ولديها
منتخب شاب وصاعد وهي جاده في كافه الماتش
مباريات بعكس المنتخبات التي اصابها نوعا
من الغرور نوع من التكبر والتعالي على كره
القدم وهو ما حدث اليوم في مباراه
البرازيل وكرواتيا عقب تسجيل نيمار
لهدف الاول وكان هذا هو هدف الفوز وترى
المنتخب البرازيلي حتى منيت شباكه بهذا
الهدف الكرواتي وقلبت الطاوله بواسطه
البطل الاول لكرواتيا اليوم وهو حارس
المرمى طيب يبدو ان قبل المباراه الثانيه
ال- ال- الجمهور الارجنتيني كان سعيدا جدا
بهذه النتيجه وكاله يصفق للنتيجه وكان
يقول يعني خلاص انت خلصت من البرازيل لان
الحدود
لا يكون مالي ايده كمان نقول بشكل كبير من
ان تكون النتيجه اذا تواجهها مع كرواتيا
بان يفوز معه هولندا وان يتواجه مع
كرواتيا انه بالفعل سيفوز لان هذا
المونديال فيه الكثير من المفاجات انا
ممكن ان يكون يعني خيبه الامل التي
اصابتني لان انا في المنزل اشترينا الكثير
من اعلام البرازيل بصراحه ههه
هذه
[ضحك]
اموال بعد اعتقدنا ان هذا الفريق الاخر
سنحاول ذلك ههه حتى ولو بربع الثمانيه ههه
اراد ان يصل النتيجه التي حققها بيليه اي
77 هدف لما سجل الهدف خلاص يعني بالنسبه
له يعني هذا فيه داخل في اطار النجوم نجوم
المونديال وتضخم الانا لديه والمنتخبان
ايضا البرازيلي والارجنتيني للاسف يعني من
الملاحظه انه ما يعتمدان على لا يحبه لاعب
واحد انا هداف المنتخب همم
المنتخب بين البرازيلي ولا الارجنتيني
هناك همم تركيز على هداف المنتخب وكان هو
من يعول عليه لتسجيل كافه الاهداف وربما
لذلك بعد ان سجل الهدف لم يكن يدرك ان
كرواتيا همم تتدارك الامر وتسجل هدف
التعادل يعني ترك الاشياء بيد اكلات
الترجيح هذه هذه المساله اعتقد انها يعني
مربوطه باكثر به الحظوظ حتى وليس فقط همم
يعني قدره اللاعبين على تسجيل الاهداف
قوسين يعني ننتظر هذه المباراه بين
البرتغال والمغرب حتى على الاقل نقول ان
ننتهي من هذه العقده عقده الوصول الى نصف
النهائي كاس العالم وربما هذا سيكون مثالا
يحتذى بالنسبه للفراق العربيه ولا افريقيا
وهنا انا متفائل جدا ان يحقق فريق المغرب
نتيجه ايجابيه ويسجل رقم تاريخ اذا نظرت
الى منتخب المغرب المغرب من حيث الفنيات
والعنصر المهم في هذه المعادله هو نظريه
الارض والجمهور وانا في تقدير الشخص ان
دوله قطر قدمت نموذج
وتشرفت الامه العربيه جميعا وحتى يعني
ربما تكون هذه افضل
التنظيمات التي صبغت الكؤوس لمناسبات
سابقه وبالتالي المنتخب المغربي يمتلك
الارض والجمهور باعتبار ان الجمهور العربي
والافريقي جميعه ملتف حول المغرب هذا
بالاضافه لانه فريق يتميز بعناصر اللعبه
الاساسيه من فنيات وتكتيك وما الى ذلك انا
متفائل واتمنى ان يحقق المغرب ما فشلت في
بعض الفرق الافريقيه والعربيه ليس بعد كل
الفرق الافريقيه والعربيه ليس بعد كل كل
كل العالم
احمد جمعه
ولو ان عدد الاصابات تحدث عن ثلاثه اصابات
المنتخب المغربي كلهم من الدفاع ومن وسط
الدفاع المغربي وهذا ربما يطرح اشكال
بالتاكيد لكن المنتخب المغربي قادر على
تحقيق المفاجاه هو منتخب عربي بمواصفات
اوروبيه يعني لك ان تتخيل ان هناك 20
لاعبا من اصل 26 لاعب يلعبون في الدوريات
الاوروبيه لفرنسا في هولندا في بلجيكا 14
لاعب ولدوا في دول الاوروبيه وبالتالي
لديهم اساسيات كره القدم الصحيحه وتربوا
في كان في هذه المدارس الاوروبيه المرموكه
في كره القدم تحصلوا على خبرات كبيره
الاتحاد المغربي لكره القدم كان له دور
كبير وبارز في الارتقاء بمستوى اللعبه من
خلال تقويه بطوله الدوري المحلي للسعانه
بمدرب وطني شاب لديه اا خبرات واسعه وقد
حقق بطولات مع نادي الوداد المغربي سواء
بطوله الدوري او حتى بطوله افريقيا على
حساب النادي الاهلي المصري فضلا عن اهم من
ذلك هي الثقافه ثقافه اللاعب التي يعني
اكتسبها من الملاعب الاوروبيه بانه قادر
على الوصول لابعد نقطه وكيف لقاها وهم
يمتلكون افضل العناصر يعني اشرف حكيمي في
باريس سان جيرمان همم سفيان مرابط
فيرونتينا الايطالي همم لاعبين اخرين في
بايرن ميونخ في الدوري البلجيكي الدوري
الهولندي همم ثلاثه لاعبين فقط من الدوري
المحلي حارس مرمى و- اا عطيه الله لاعب
يلعب في الجناح الايسر ولاعب اخر يلعب في
المنتصف لا يشاركون بشكل اساسي لكن الطموح
الكبير لدى المنتخب المغربي الالتفاف
الكبير همم حرص الاتحاد المغربي على يعني
تصفير اسر اللاعبين لمؤازرهم بشكل كبير
الارتباط القوي بين همم اللاعبين المغاربه
وبين اثرهم وقد تجلى ذلك في المقاطع
المصوره التي نشرت سواء بروفايل وهو يتحدث
مع والدته قبل راسها وكذلك اشرف حكيمي
الذي يرتبط بشكل كبير مع امه ويراها هي
النموذج المصغر للمغرب هذه الدوله التي
يجب ان يقدمها الكثير والكثير من اجل من
اجل اسعاد الشعب المغربي بشكل خاص والشعب
العربي بشكل عام الذي يشجع المغرب ويقف
خلفها ويرى ان هذا النموذج الناجح يجب ان
يتم الاحتذاء به في الدول العربيه يجب ان
تعمل المنظومات في الدول العربيه على
اتباع هذا ان نهج المغربي بالسماح للاعبين
بالاحتراف في الخارج همم فضلا عن ضروره
تغيير الثقافه اللاعب العربي الذي لا يحب
الالتزام كثيرا لذا تفشل العديد من
التجارب الاحترافيه ويعود اللاعبين العرب
بعكس المغربي الذي يعني امضي سنوات كبيره
وطويله في دوريات الاوروبيه ويثابر ويصبر
ويتدرب
وليد الرجراجي على المنتخب العراقي
تشتهر وتتعب وتكد وتعرف هذه هي المنتخبات
التي تفوز وهي التي تتقدم على المنتخبات
الكبيره والمصنفه تصنيفا اوليا في همم
الفيفا كل التوفيق للمنتخب المغربي همم
غدا همم هذه البطوله السياسيه بالتاكيد
ونتمنى نحن العرب ان يصل المنتخب المغربي
الى المباراه النهائيه وهذا ليس بمستحيل
خلاص
في شكل صاروخي ههه اكثر من اللي عامل لها
عجينه كره القدم في في المونديال ولكن اهم
وليد الرجراجي وجود وليد الرجراجي منذ
قدومه استغل ان استطاع ان يستفيد من هذه
الخبرات التي اكتسبها اللاعبون في
المنتخبات او في الفرق
النوادي
العالميه الدوليه الغربيه تحديدا
وكذلك اكسبهم ثقه بانفسهم اكبر كمنتخب
مغربي همم لاحظنا هذا الانسجام التمدرس
والانضباط والالتزام الذي تحدث عنه همم
احمد جمعه من القاهره لهذا الالتزام همم
استفاد منه وليد راجي ووظفه بشكل جيد
جعلهم ربما حتى وان كانوا في مباراههم مع
الاخيره كانوا يعني همم ربما سيطر على
الفريق المضاد على همم على ملعبهم ولكن
رغم ذلك لاحظنا همم تمطر
دفاعيا او اوروبا حتى وصفه والكثير من
المعلق الرياضيين هنا في اوروبا بالدفاع
العسكري وكانه دفاع عسكري عن شباكه هم لكي
لا تسجل فيها اي اهداف ولكن وليد رجراجي
بالفعل حتى المغاربه انفوسهم انفسهم
يتحدثون عن هذا الدور الذي لاعبه بشكل
كبير وغير مستوى المنتخب في هذه المباريات
خالد خرجنا من تلك الكلام الذي نسمعه
المشكله هو ان الجمهور العربي لاي فريق
لاي منتخب عنده بينزم الفريق
يحاول ان يحدد مثل ما تحدث الضيفه من
القاهره هذا مولود في فرنسا هذا مولود في
بريطانيا لا يمكن له يتمتع بروح وطنيه
باعتبار انهم ولد في بلد اجنبي ولكن عندما
يفوزون
نتاكد بانه بالفعل يلعبون بطريقه وبارتباط
كبير بالبلد القصر وهذا ما اظهره المنتخب
المغربي انه ان كنت مولودا في اسبانيا او
في كندا او في فرنسا وفي بلجيكا وفي
هولندا عندما تلعب مع فريقك فان العالم هو
الاساس
مجموعه العلاقه
بين اللاعب المقيم في اوروبا يعني نشا في
اوروبا ولكنه يرتبط روحيا ووجدانيا مع
دوله الاصل معظم المجتمعات كما تعلم اخي
توفيق معظم المجتمعات العربيه المهاجره في
اوروبا ارتبطت ارتباط مثيل بثقفاته ونغلت
كل هذه التجارب الى دول اوروبا وبالتاكيد
هؤلاء اللاعبين بالرغم من انهم ربما ولدوا
في دول اوروبيه ونشاتهم الاولى وتعلموا في
كثير من المجالات ولكنهم ما زالوا عن
ارتباط مثير بمجتمعاتهم اثارهم حتى
الحوادث المستمعيه في اوروبا لبعض
الجاليات المهاجره
لاتحتفظ بهويتها الاصليه وبعداته
وبتقاليده وهذا الارتباط الوجداني الكبير
وبالتاكيد ربما الفكره الاساسيه التي
تناوله ضيفك احمد من القاهره هي يعني اساس
الانطلاق باعتبار ان هذه الجيل من
اللاعبين المغاربه هم نشاوا في اوروبا
تعلموا ونهلوا منها كل الاساسيات اللعبه
من ناحيه نشاه والتجارب الفنيه والتدريب
وما الى ذلك ولكن اتعد لهم الظروف ان يقدم
هذه التجربه كانت جميل لشعوب مجتمعاتهم
وبالتاكيد المجتمع المغربي وكما تعلم
ومعظم المجتمعات العربيه هي ترتبط ارتباط
وثيق بحواضينا المجتمعيه سواء كان في
اوروبا او في
دول الامه الاصل يعني ولكن نحن بطبعها اخي
توفيق الشعوب عربيه وافريقيه
اول ما تجد الانسان ابدع في مجال ربما يجد
نوع من الاشاده والتقدير ولكن ربما في
حاله تحصد به الاقدار بعكس ما تاهو هذه
المجتمعات ينال ما ينال من فقط وغضب وانا
اتمنى ان يصل بين المغرب الى درجه اعلى من
هذه الروح المقبولين موجوده الان حتى نتوج
بسجل تاريخي جديد وانا صيغه ان المنتخب
المغربي الذي شاهدته قادر ان يفعل
المستحيل وان يحقق المفاجاه كبيره ربما
تدفع هذه المجتمعات ونحن جميعا
ليس فقط المجتمع في حد ذاته كيف اذا كان
يعطي تقديرا امنا اللاعب ولكن حتى الجهاد
الرياضيه الرسميه داخل الدوله الام طريقه
التعاطي مع اللاعبين حجم الامكانيات التي
توفرها لهؤلاء لكي يلعبوا في كاس العالم
يعني همم مثل همم ذكر الضيفه انا مساله
الاهتمام بعائله بعائلات اللاعبين
بتسفيرهم همم يعني احتضان كل ذلك يؤثر على
اللاعب عندما يلعب
داخل في صفوف منتخبه الوطني
لا عفوا لاحمد كل الجمهور المصري مع
المغرب نعم كل الجمهور المصري يوم السبت
مع المغرب
المصري بل كل الجمهور العربي حتى الدول
التي لديها خلافات بينيه مع المملكه
المغربيه جمهور هذه الدول يشجع المغرب وهو
ما يؤكد ان الرياضه قادره على حل المشكلات
البينيه ما بين الشعوب ما بين الدول قادره
على التقريب ما بين الشعوب الرياضه وحدها
هي التي تكسر همم عزله العزله التي تفرض
من قبل بعض الكائنات او المؤسسات او
الحكومات العربيه كارثه تشجع المنتخب
ههه
التمدرس خلف الانتماءات بعيدا عن المظله
الوطنيه
وهي المنتخب الوطني لذا نحن كما قلت في
مجتمعنا العربيه ودولنا العربيه في حاجه
لاصلاح المنظومات الرياضيه بشكل كامل لما
يعتري هذه المنظومات من فساد وواسطه
ومحسوبيه في بعض الدول وهو ما يؤدي ضياع
واندثار مواهب عظيمه يمكن ان تقدم الكثير
والكثير للكره العربيه لذا نحن في حاجه
الى الثوره رياضيه عربيه حقيقيه
للنهوض بهذا القطاع المهم لدينا الكثير من
المواهب التي تهاجر الى اوروبا ويتم
تجنيسها وترتدي اا يعني تيشرتات منتخبات
اوروبيه ويكون هؤلاء احد ابرز واعظم لاعبي
العالم القاره الافريقيه والدول العربيه
ينقصها فقط التقطيط الجيد ينقصها فقط ان
يتم مكافحه الفساد همم والواسطه
والمحسوبيه في بعض الاتحادات الرياضيه
وانطلاقا من هذا الامر يتم الاصلاح في
منظومه الكهف نفسه ليكون العرب والافارقه
قادرون على المنافسه في المربع الذهبي
وعلى كاس العالم وميلا وليله ولدينا احد
اعظم لاعبي العالم من اصول افريقيه
حتى الان من يقود القاره وشمال افريقيا مع
ان كانت تحويل على دول
والكاميرون
الاخيره من الامل في هذا الفريق المغربي
وهناك من يعني حتى طريقه التشبه ليست على
تتحدث حدود الرياضه ايضا هناك من يعتبر
انتصار المغرب في اي مباراه هو انتصار
للمنطقه العربيه
شايف ان في حاجه ان تظهري بحاجه لاي شيء
ايجابي صحيح و ايضا
مباراه المغرب
اعاده فتح الاندلس من جديد ههه هناك اشياء
كثيره
او في مجال الرياضه كثير جدا من العرب
والافارقه المهاجرين ابدعوا في مجالات
اخرى مختلفه تحققت اغراض او جندانت
لان ما توفره الملاعب لا توفره لا تلفزات
ولا وسائل الاعلام ولا وسائل
كره كره
لا احد يعطيني الفرصه في بلدانهم ليس فقط
في مجال الرياضه كثير جدا من العرب تميزه
في مجالات مختلفه في العلوم في الطب في
الهندسه ولكن لم لم يجدوا الفرصه لكيسر ما
لديهم من قدرات والتاهيل وكفاءه بالتاكيد
هذه المزانه تعود به الذكر العدد من
المجالات التي تميز فيها عدد من الاخوه
العرب والافارقه في اوروبا في فرنسا في
امريكا في بريطانيا ولكن لم تتطلط عليه
عليهم الاضواء كما يجب والمنتخب المغربي
استطاع بهؤلاء الشباب ان يعكس جدليه ان
البيئه التي يمكن ان توفر الابداع هي ممكن
ان تبحث في عالمنا العربي والاسلامي
والافريقي ولكن بيكون اسف وانا العادات
والتقاليد والمحسوبيه والفساد كما تفضل
ضيف الاستاذ احمد من القاهره هي العقبه
الكود التي يجب ان نتجاوزها جميعا حتى هذه
المجتمعات هناك كثير جدا من الفنانين
التشكيليين المبدعين العازفين المغنيين في
مجال الفنون كثير جدا
التميز ولكن بيكون اسف لا يوجد التق
والانتباه الكبير من المجتمعات طيب اين هو
المنتخب السوداني
والله هذه واحده من الاساسيات ههه اذا اذا
اذا عدنا
اذا السودان
جنوب افريقيا ولا نيجيريا ولا
الكاميرا السودان
اثيوبيا كانوا الدول الثلاثه التي اسست
الاتحاد الافريقي لكره القدم والسودان فاز
بالكاس الافريقي في عام 70 ولكن منذ ذلك
العام الى يومنا هذا ظل السودان متفرجين
لا توجد الانديه ليس فقط في السودان عند
الدول في المنطقه يعني حتى الفرق الصغيره
الناشئه لا تجد همم ميزانيه كافيه لكي
تتوفر لها البنا التحتيه ولا حتى يعني
قمصان للاعب كره القدم ولا اي شيء ولا
احذيه ولا اي شيء من ذلك
[موسيقى]
من قبل عندما جاءت ونزرت في لندن همم
الاولمبياد 2012 همم تقابل او تقابلت
اللاعب البرازيلي الشهير بيليه وكنت من
ضمن الفريق الذي ربما يتحرك في داخل
الفعاليات ومع المجموعه نفسها يعني مجموعه
من الاشخاص من بينهم فذكر لي كيف انه عنده
ذهب الى السودان ولعب في سانتوس مع فريق
غير الهلال والمريخ وقال لي نصرا انه لم
يقابل فريق كما هو حال الهلال في
السبعينات وهزم هو الحقيقه وتعادلوا مع
الهلال وربما كانت نتيجه المباراه بالنسبه
لي وعالقه في البال والوجدان فهذا يعني
مثلا حديث
الصور حتى نراها لنادي سوارنا
صور يعني صور فيديو
والله عندي بعض
الصور فوتوغرافيه
يا استاذ
محمد صلاح
الكره المصريه الاهلي والزمالك كان يلعب
في المقاولون ويسافر لاقص اكثر من خمس او
ست ساعات بالقطار وكان لا يجد يعني
الاموال الكافي للتنقل الى نادي المقاولون
كي يؤدي التدريبات صلاح الان بجهود فرديه
وذاتيه احد اعظم لاعبي العالم هذا ما
نتحدث عنه اعطاء الفرص للمواهب الشابه
والتي لديها موهبه والقادره على خدمه
المنتخب الوطني هذه الانجازات الفرديه
والذاتيه التي يقوم بها اللاعبين المصريين
سواء عمر مرموش او محمد صلاح او محمد
النني في ارسنال كلها خرجوا بجهود ذاتيه
وفرديه دون اي تخطيط للاسهال
هنا التوفيق الذي ذكرته همم الذي عليك ان
فريق بحجم سانتوس البرازيلي عندما يلعب في
السودان في السبعينات وياتي لكي يلعب
مباريات وديه مع فريقيا الهلال والمريخ في
السودان هذا دلال على ان السودان كان في
درجه متقدمه من الالياذه ولكن بيكون للاسف
الان ربما لغير الهلال والمريخ يلعبون في
المنافسات الافريقيه المتقدم ولكن ظل
المنتخب الغوام غالبا عن هذه المحادثه
الدوليه الكبيره ربما الشغل الشاغل حاليا
في السودان وهذا الاتفاق بين العسكري
والمدنيين لا انتم يعني عندكم همم مباراه
كره قدم سياسيه حاليا ليست مباراه كره قدم
لها علاقه ههه
بالمواضيع المونديال كم سياسي في الخرطوم
هناك من رحبه هناك من يضل يعارض صح
نيكول تاكيد هو المونديال السياسي هذا
يعني العكس سلفا على كل
الاجهزه الصعود الاخرى بالتاكيد انعكس على
كل الواقع المجتمع السوداني نعم لدينا
اتفاق سياسي هذه الايام فيما عريض بالاطار
السياسي ولكن هو نفسه مصدر تجاذب بين
المكونات السياسيه باعتبار انه لا يحقق
اغراض كثير من الناس وعلى راس ذلك لجان
المقاومه والثوره الفاعله كما هو حال
الاحزاب اليساريه الحزب الشيوعي حزب البحث
بعض المكونات شخص اليمين احزاب نداء
السودان
للكبار والصناعه خارجيه وهذه التومه لم
تاتي من فروع انما جائت من فادات القائمين
على امر هذا الاتفاق باعتبار انه صدر عن
لجنه نقابه المحامين همم
في السودان وبالتالي هذا كان مثار جدل
باعتبار ان النغابه لم تكن همم منتخبه وهي
للنقابه تقوم باعمال في هذه الفتره
وبالتالي هذا الدستور مشكوك فيه باعتبار
التدخل الدولي وهذا السودان كما تعلم ان
هناك حساسيه مفرد اتجاه كل ما هو دخيل
ويرسم في الخارج لدينا تجارب كثيره فشلت
وعلى راس اتفاقيه السلام الشامل التي وقعت
في نيباشا عام 2005 والتي انتهت بانفصال
الجنوب وافق على ملفات خطره وقنابل موجوده
كما هو حال همم ترسيم الحدود بين ذلك من
قضايا وبالتاكيد هذا جدا ماذا يراعي
المكان ربما يعني الايام المقبله ستشهد
نوع من التطورات في سبيل التدارك هذا
الامر همم بهذا الاتجاهات اما ان يجد دعم
شعبي ومجتمعي كبير وا جد رفض اكبر
وبالتالي نحن في خدم معادله سياسيه مختلفه
الى حد كبير في هذا مجرد يعني
ذلك ولكن مجرد
الجانب العسكري بالاقرار باحقيه الجانب
المدني في الحكم
الى هذه النقطه حتى ما كانت مجرد
تصريحاتها الان هناك مخاوف لدى القوه اا
يعني المدنيه وان كان وهناك عدم توافق
وعدم وحده صف بين القوى المدنيه هذا وهذا
كان الاشكال الاكبر في كل مره يتم فيها
همم التواصل الى اتفاق يتم همم يعني همم
وصفه من يوقع على اتفاق مع الجانب العسكري
همم نيوتن بالخيانه ووصفه بال- وهنا كمان
يقاطع وهذا هو سبب الاشكال وايضا ربما
الادوار التي يقوم بها همم الاتحاد
الاوروبي ويقوم بها المجتمع الدولي ان كان
المبعوث الامريكي او او غير المبعوث
الامريكي لم تصل الى حد ال- ال- الحزم او
الاهتمام بشكل كبير وواضح همم وحقيقي
بالملف السوداني مكان هذا الملف يؤخر او
يترك
الاشياء الداخلي هنا تكون المشكله ايضا
ال الجميع احمد جمعه طبعا من القاهره لن
اسالك عن حلايب ولكن بالتاكيد استقرار
السودان هو من استقرار مصر واهتمام كبير
بما يجري على الساحه السودانيه
خالد راح الصوت
الان كيف يمكن تخطي هذه المرحله في هذا
الظرف بالذات كيف يمكن اقناع شريحه كبيره
من المجتمع السوداني
تسمعني يا احمد
كيف يمكن تخطي هذه المرحله شريحه كبيره
تعارض مثل هذا الاتفاق
رابط
النصر
المكونات المهنيه هي التي شكلت ملامح
المشهد الحالي باعتبار ان التيمم على
المهنيين السودانيين هو الذي ربما اثار
فتره الثوره قبل السقوط 11 2019 وبالتالي
من هنا ابدا الجدل ولكن يمكن تعرف هذا
الامر بتاعه الفرصه للمكونات السودانيه
والكتل لكي تجلس في ما بينها وتصل الى
الصيغه التوافق عبر وصيغه وطنيه همم لا
تلغي طرف تاتي هذه التسيريه بما لديها من
طرح وياتو هؤلاء
الفراغات بما لديهم من الطرقات اخرى لكي
يدمجها ويخرجوا بالصيغه توافق وطني
السودان لا يمكن ان يلغي طرف طرف اخر
لدينا تجربه امتدت خرابه الاربعه اعوامره
هذه اللحظه وحصلت وحدث فيها الكثير جدا من
الكيد السياسي وهذا الكيد السياسي
همم الشعب السوداني وانا كدوله وافغرها
وهذا الامر يحتاج الى معالجه وطنيه صادقه
ما لم تتوافق الغور الوطنيه في الصيغه
توافق حول رؤيه مشتركه للفتره الانتقاليه
سيبقى الحاله على موضوع عليها
من كما ذكرت لا يمكن اخفاء طرف ولكن هناك
مثلا كل من يتبع النظام السابق يريدون
اقصاء هناك من يريد اخصاء الاسلام السياسي
اول مره هنا يقع التصادم والمواجهه بين
القوه تحديدا المدنيه هي التي تحتلها
بالملف السوداني كنت طرحت عليك السؤال
تفضل
هذا الاتفاق الاخير اتفاق الايطالي عندما
تقرا هذا الاتفاق يعني للوهله الاولى تظن
انه مثاليه لكن المشكل يكمن في التفاصيل
عندما يتم تطبيق هذه البنود على الارض هو
حتى الان اتفاق اطار لم يتم التوقيع عليه
بشكل نهائي لكن هناك بعض الملفات التي تم
تاخيرها الى المرحله الثانيه ما قبل
التوقيع وهي ملفات مهمه للغايه العداله
الانتقاليه همم كيفيه همم يعني دمج همم
قوات الدعم السريع على سبيل المثال تركت
بشكل مفتوح لم يتم تحديد اليه او مده
زمنيه هذا الامر حدث ايضا في اتفاق
الترتيبات الامنيه اتفاق جو على سبيل
المثال حدد ترتيبات الامنيه ان تطبق في
مده سته اشهر وحتى الان لمده اكثر من
عامين لم يتم اا تطبيق هذا الاتفاق
والتوافق عليه ايضا فكره الاصلاح داخل
المؤسسه العسكريه من سيتولى هذا الامر هل
السلطه المدنيه ام همم سلطه الجيش في ظل
همم تلميح السيد الفريق عبد الفتاح
البرهان بضروره ان يترك اساس الشؤون
المهنيه للعسكريين واللا يتدخلوا في هذا
الامر انا ارى ان المشكل يكمن في التدخلات
الخارجيه الانقسام الداخلي بين المكونات
المدنيه والاطراف السياسيه السودانيه التي
تعمل على قاعده الغلبه من يغلب الاخر في
ظل غياب حاله التوافق المشكله في همم دول
شمال افريقيا بشكل كامل وليس في السودان
فقط هو عدم تطبيق ما يتم الاتفاق عليه ولا
لعل انا نموذج الليبي والاستاذ سعد مطلع
على ذلك يتم الاتفاق توقيع اتفاقات ولا
يتم الالتزام باي اتفاق
ملتقى
عشرات الاتفاقيه صحيح
هذه الاتفاقات والسودان كذلك تدخلات
الخارجيه لها اثر سلبي اثر سلبي كبير
السكان في الحاله السودانيه او في الحاله
الليبيه وجود عده مجموعات مسلحه ولديها
قدره ولديها ايضا حواضا اجتماعيه ولديها
همم يعني القدره الدفاعيه والسياحه
لديها مصالح مختلفه ههه المشكله لدينا في
السودان استاذ توفيق والاخوه الكرام
المشكله في السودان ان كل الاتفاقات
السلامه التي تمت في السودان بلا استثناء
ما عدا اتفاقتين ربما هي تمت في الخارج
وتمت بتصنيع خارجي
اتفاقتين تموه الاولى كانت في الدوحه خاصه
بالتفاق سلام دافور الاول والثانيه كانت
ايضا في اسمر
في هذين الاتفاقين تم اتحاد الفرصه
للسودان لكشاوروا
بعيدا عن اي جندات سياسيه او املائه
خارجيه وربما نجحت هذه الاتفاقات وانتهت
الى شراكات معلومه
بشي وانتهام باتفاقيه السلامه الشامل التي
وقعت في نيفاشا في كينيا كانت بتخطيط
وبقوه الدفع خارجي وانا كتبت في هذا النص
في هذا المجال من قبل التوفيق واسميت عديد
عدد من المقالات اتفاغات سلام السودان خطا
التصنيع طال ما صحبتها معدله اساسيه في
خطاب في التصنيع لا لان المصنعين لهذه
الاتفاقات لا يدركون حجم التعليق الداخلي
وليست لديهم معرفه كامله بخصوصيه المجتمع
السوداني يريد التصنيع في نقص مكونات
صينيه ههه
في تصنيعها درجه ثانيه لانه
ارتفاعات سلام وقعت في دول اخرى كما هو
الحال في جنوب افريقيا او ما الى ذلك في
الواقع السوداني الذي هو مختلف تماما من
حيث البنيه والتشكيل والتركيب والمجتمعيه
وبالتالي من المهم ان يجلس السودانيين في
ما بينهم بيتوافقوا حول رؤيه سياسيه
سودانيه خاصه
فراغ يملاه هذا العمل الخارجي
ويصوبون اهدافهم نحو الكرسي والجلوس في
دائره اتخاذ القرار لو لو لو التزم الجميع
بجثير ان الفتره
لما تدخل مبنى المجلس العسكري في السودان
وترى الكراسي فعلا كراسي كذا يعني ههه
مغريه جدا
يعني كرسي يعني
وانت قد جلست في احد هذه الكراسي وفي تخش
عليك ان لا تعود الى فرنسا
[ضحك]
يبدو هي الحل الوحيد في العراق والبعض
يطالب بها في سوريا وكذلك في ليبيا والان
في السودان الجميع يطالب بالمناصب
وبالكراسي ويبدو ان المحاصصه سواء
الطائفيه او المناطقيه او الجهويه هي التي
ستسود خلال الفتره المقبله
حصه
في نهايه المطاف ما لديه من لا يمتلك اي
حصه في اي اتفاق هنا المشكله يعني في كل
هذه الدول لان همم ولا توجد اليه لمعاقبه
من يعرف العمليه السياحيه التاريخ
يعني ما يمكن ان يكون حجم التناغم بين
العرب والصين
يعني
يتحدث بطريقه ويتحدث عن عن المساله
الامنيه في المنطقه وعن قضايا كبيره وكانه
يعني يقول للولايات المتحده انا الان في
المنطقه وانا من سيعوض من سبقوني ولم
يقدموا ما كانت تنتظر هذه الدول وناسه
تقدم البديل
اكيد بالنظر الى علاقات همم المنطقه
العربيه عموما وفيقيا مع الصين منذ مئات
السنين طريق الحرير وتعلم ذلك هناك روابط
بين العرب والصين اكثر من تلك التي تربطهم
مع القربه الحديثه تقصد طريق الحريري
القديم القديم والجديد الذي سياتي هم
القديم
يعني هذه قيمه تحاول ان تصيبه في شكل جديد
حتى تتم وفق تلك النظريه تصميم لعلاقات
جديده وحتى المؤتمر نفسه سمي بعنوان معا
من اجل السلام والهدف هو تعزيز العلاقات
التاريخيه بكل تاكيد هذا الاساس ومعلومه
نصين اكبر توفي فيها اكبر شريك له معظم
هذه الدول العربيه
لم تكن
والله انا في تقديري ستكون
ستكون بحول الله
يرتبط ايضا بمبررات القمه التي تمت في
داكار ودشرت طريق السكه الحديد من
بورسودان الى العاصمه
الاولى في تعميميه خازن العلاقات
فيما عرف بمبادره التنميه العالميه التي
يعرض عنها الصين سبتمبر 2021 وكذلك
استراتيجيه المعلومه التي هي بنيت على
المبادره العربيه همم والمبادره السعوديه
الاخيره في ما يلي الشرق الاوسط الاخضر
ودعم المبادره مبادره السلام لديها مواقف
تاريخيه كبيره معظم الدول العربيه
ايضا كانت في استراتيجياتها تنويع هذه
الشركات يعني هي محاوله لعدم الانجراف الى
عالم القطب الواحد الدول العربيه تريد
ايضا ان ترسل رسائل بان يكون العالم متعدد
الاقصى يعني هي محاوله فقط
شرف المحاوله هناك فقط انا اوصول مجيء
الرئيس الصيني الى المملكه السعوديه كانت
بدعوه من السعوديه هي دين ليست رساله فقط
صينيه لي العالم ولكن
هناك ههه
عندما نعود الى عام 2019 لما المملكه
العربيه السعوديه كانت لوحه كانت هناك
تقارير في دفاس نيوز وفي معهد ستوكه
الماليه حتى السلام تحدث عن هذه التلوحات
السعوديه لعدم التعامل بالدولار في بعض
همم
الواردات والمعاملات الدولاريه الغاء بعض
المعاملات الدولاريه كان وقتها هناك همم
نوعا ما همم نوع من التهديد الامريكي دول
اوبا كبير ملاحقه هذه الدول بتهمه
الاحتكار اذا هناك رسائل دوما متبادله
هناك نوع من الفجوه التي نشات بين المملكه
السعوديه بين دول الخليج وبين الخليفه
الاستراتيجي الولايات المتحده اذا هذه
الزياره تاتي في ظل ظروف متعدده بما فيها
الحرب الاوكرانيه وملف الطاقه الذي اصبح
على راس الاولويات فا- همم وايضا في اعقاب
الحديث عن السلاح وانا الولايات المتحده
تغير استراتيجتها في مساله السلاح للدول
العربيه وتحديدا لدول الخليج في كل مره
هناك بديل هذه المره هو الصين اذا عوامل
كثيره ورسائل كثيره يتوجه هذه الاطراف ان
ترسلها للولايات المتحده
ولي العهد السعودي محمد بن سلمان
تاريخيه تاريخيه جديد للعلاقه بين الصين
والسعوديه تعدل وتعميق التعاون مع جمهوريه
الصين الشعبيه في جميع المجالات والى
التنسيق وجهات النظر خلال القضايا
الاقليميه والدوليه دول مجلس رفع مستوى
هذا التعاون الى افاق ارحب كما نشير
الارتفاع الملحون في حجم التبادلات
التجاريه بين دول مجلس التعاون والجمهوريه
الصين الشعبيه خلال السنوات الماضيه التي
تتوقع ان تستمر في النمو بعد تناول
المفاوضات الخاصه باقامه منطقه تجاريه حره
بين الجانبين ونشارك التفكير مع اصدقائنا
في الصين حول اهميه اعاده توجيه تركيب
المجتمع الدولي نحو التعاون والتنميه
والتنميه والمجابه التحديات ومشتركه التي
تواجه الانسانيه
ماذا قال الضيف سجن بينك
التعاون الخليجي للحفاظ على امنها وستواصل
دعم دول المنطقه لتعمل على حل الخلافات
بالحوار والتشاور وعلى بناء هيكل للامن
الجماعي في الخليج
وايضا الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي رئيس
المصري تحدث عن هذا الموضوع
فقد كانت السياسات الصينيه المتوازنه
المتوازنه اتجاه مختلف القضيه العربيه
بشكل عام وتجاه القضيه الفلسطينيه بشكل
خاص ودعم الجانب الصيني لحق الفلسطيني
المشروع في اقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه على
خطوط الرابع من يونيو 1967
وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه محل تقدير واحترام
بالغين في العالم العربي ولقد بداله الدول
العربيه تلك المواقف الصينيه المتزنه
والدعمه بمواقض مسانده للصين ومتفهمها
لقضاياها وشغلها
احمد جمعه واضح ان الرساله هي بالدرجه
الاولى الى الولايات المتحده
زياره وهذه القمه قمه تاريخيه من الرئيس
الصيني في ظل تشكل النظام العالمي الجديد
عقب الحرب الاوكرانيه هذا النظام العالمي
المتعدد لابد ان يكون للدول العربيه موضع
قدم في هذا النظام العالمي الجديد الذي
يتشكل والا يتم لا تهنيش الدول العربيه
وان تكون فاعلا في هذا النظام وليس مفعولا
به هذه زياره تتويجا للعلاقات التاريخيه
ما بين الدول العربيه والصين التي تمتد
لاكثر من الفي عام التبادل التجاري الذي
وصل لحوالي 330 مليار دولار خلال العام
الماضي همم التبادل التجاري ما بين مصر
على سبيل المثال والصين وصل ل 20 مليار
دولار وما بين السعوديه والصين دي 90
مليار دولار كل هذا يشير الى مدى تطور هذه
العلاقات ليس على المستوى التجاري او
الاقتصادي فقط ولكن على مستوى السياسي
الصين تتبع سياسه متوازنه بعكس الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه التي باتت غير محايده
في بعض الملفات وعلى سبيل المثال القضيه
الفلسطينيه هي منحازه الى الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بشكل كامل والقضيه الفلسطينيه
هي القضيه المركزيه للدول العربيه هذه
الوثيقه السياسيه هذا البيان الذي صدر
اليوم والذي يؤكد على عدد من الثوابت
العربيه الصينيه ومنها موقف الطرفان من
القضيه الفلسطينيه وكذلك موقف الدول
العربيه من الصين الموحده التي تعتبر
تايوان جزءا لا يتجزا من الصين واحترام
سياده الدول وعدم فرد اي املاءات خارجيه
او همم محاوله استقطاب الدول العربيه في
لعبه المحاور همم الدوليه وعدم مراعات
الشواغر العربيه الدول العربيه لديها
شواغر والاهم عنوان هذه القمه وهي التعاون
والتنميه هي قمه ليست موجهه الى اي طرف
خارجي هي تحرك عربي مهم هو متاخر لكن ان
تاتي متاخرا افضل من لا تاتي بضروره
التنويع همم الشركات الاستراتيجيه
اهم ايضا بالنسبه للمملكه السعوديه احمد
بنسبه المملكه السعوديه او حتى بالنسبه لي
لدور العربيه
او رئيس امريكا الى المنطقه القاده العرب
يطلب منهم المشاركه يلعبون عندما يتعلق
الامر باجتماع عربي عربي في عاصمه عربيه
قوه دوليه ان كانت اقتصاديه وقوه عسكريه
الكل يكون حاضرا لانها لا لا تغير العالم
العربي يحاول ان يكون ولكن في تشتتوتي لا
يمكن ان يكون قوه كبرى دون ان يكون تكاتلا
في مواجهه التكتلات كبرى ايضا ولكن اليوم
بس السبب في هذا التدخلات عربيه الخارجيه
التي تتنقل في شؤون الدول العربيه وتغزل
الانقسامات والسرعات على سبيل المثال في
السودان او حتى في ليبيا او ما بين المغرب
والجزائر اطراف خارجيه هي من تحجج وتعزز
هذا الصراحه حتى في سوريا في العراق في
اليمن وفي لبنان هذه التدخلات الغربيه هي
التي تقدم الانقسامات البينيه
ما يميزها من وجهه نظر عربيه بنسبه لدول
العربيه لا تتحدث الحقوق الانسان
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه لا يفتح اي
موضوع داخلي هو فقط يتحدث عن الصفقات وان
كانت همم تجاريه او عسكريه ولا يتحدث عن
امور اخرى داخليه تونس الطرف المضيف العكس
همم جو بعيدا عندما يقوم به زيارته رئيس
امريكي فهو يضع ملف حقوق الانسان على راس
الاولويه
لذلك يثير الانسان
اا تقول رغم ذلك لا يمكن لي الصينه تكون
بديله عن العلاجات الولايات المتحده وهذا
ما تقول الاطراف في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه كل الاعلام السعوديه تحدث لا
نستبدل شريكا بشريك ولكن هو تنويع للشركات
وارسال رساله اننا دوله ذات يده يمكننا ان
ننوع الشركات نمو ننوع مصادر السلاح
تحديدا لان خلال السنوات القليله الماضيه
هناك اتفاقيات عسكريه حول فيما يخص
الطائرات بدون طيار والصواريخ اذا تم همم
توقيعها مع الصين خلافه العلاقات
التاريخيه التجاريه المتعلقه فقط بالتجاره
والتنميه والبنا التحتيه وما الى ذلك
واليوم هناك ايضا تلعب دورا حتى لدائره
السعوديه تحديدا هذه الجزئيه هي الهامه
لان ال- ال- الصينيه الشريك الاقتصاد
الاول بنسبه لايران المشتري الاول بالنسبه
الايراني رغم العقوبات اذا من وجهه النظر
هذه يمكن ان تلعب دورا بالفعل لا يطلب
منها ان تترك ايران وان
الدوره يعني يزعج جيران ولكن ان تتعامل
كوسيط كثير من الوقت للرياضه لان لاحظت
انكم تحبون الرياضه وبالتالي المواضيع
الاخرى يعني في المرتبه الثانيه ثم
المرتبه الثالثه شكرا في الختام لسعد
الزميله ساده الصابري بالموتيكار الدوليه
وتحيه لمستمرار الدوري شكرا من القاهره
لاحمد جمعه والشكر من لندن لخالد لعسر وهو
كاتب وصافي برامجكم بالعربيه والفرنسيه
والانجليزيه همم